the bad news just doesn't stop for this
administration we now have top economic
advisor Gary cone resigning he is not
some intern who would get coffee for
Donald Trump Gary cone is the head of
the National Economic Council this is
the number-one economic advisor to the
President of the United States asked why
Gary cone is resigning the White House
said there's no one reason but of course
even an eight-year-old could identify
that Trump announces 25% tariffs on
steel 10% tariffs on aluminum disastrous
economically and then immediately the
top economic advisor resigns most likely
not a coincidence although of course
correlation is not causation and then we
later found out from the New York Times
that Gary cone had actually warned last
week that if Trump goes through with
these tariffs he might be out that might
be him riding into the sunset and I was
laughing to myself when I read this
Trump was gonna drain the swamp right
Cohn is one of the swamp investment
bankers that wasn't going to be part of
the administration to begin with Trump
is finally draining the swamp by being
so in Suffern about to work with that
people he's hired or quitting that's the
only way in which it could be reasonably
beaten reasonably be argued that Donald
Trump is doing doing any draining of the
swamp and the line from Trump is on this
that the cognitive dissonance is just
stunning the trumpets are saying listen
Gary Cohn was basically a Democrat
almost always for free trade he just
didn't really have a place in this great
administration that's making America
great again but the bigger picture is
that this is now a really long list of
people who have left people in serious
roles with the Trump administration
National Security Advisor Michael Flynn
indicted chief strategist Steve Bannon
propagandist pushed out presumably by
chief of staff John Kelly chief economic
adviser Gary Cohen is now resigning
multiple communications directors
including Anthony scaramouche
most recently Hope Hicks the neo-nazi
connected Trump advisor Sebastian Gorka
dr. Gorka as Sean Hannity lovingly
refers to him on his new job at FoxNews
deputy national security advisor katie
mcfarland rob porter we talked about in
the last couple of weeks chief of staff
Reince Priebus press secretary Sean
Spicer and these are just some of the
big names there are several dozen other
smaller roles and then of course
hundreds of unfilled positions which
I've told you about before the official
turnover number right now for the Trump
administration is 43% 43% of this core
group of positions under the purview of
the Oval Office under the purview of the
president have already turned over and
we are what March 3 to 14 months in not
even 14 months into this administration
shrinking government I guess is how you
would defend this people people are just
going away they don't want anything to
do with the government so Trump is
operating under the pretense of smaller
government still also a very long list
of upcoming potential resignations Jared
Kushner
I don't know if it's going to be
resignation or indictment or someone
just saying it's time for you to get the
hell out because you're only causing
problems we also have been hearing
multiple reports that Michael Flynn's
replacement the new national security
adviser HR McMaster is preparing to
resign will see rumors about Secretary
of State Rex Tillerson 'he's possible
resignation still haven't gone away even
though clearly hasn't happened yet and
then even the elegant chief of staff
John Kelly's name keeps coming up if we
believe the reports Kelly has been on
the verge of or sort of he was on the
other side of an ultimatum of resigning
and I don't remember exactly what the
issues were that got Kelly basically in
a position of if you do this I will have
to go I think maybe something related to
Rob Porter although now up now I'm not
exactly remembering but the list of
people who are arguably close to
resignation is a pretty big list I'm
wondering are the best people Trump was
going to hire the people that are
leaving
or the people that Trump will now have
the opportunity to hire because of all
the resignations that have taken place I
don't know and I want to take a slightly
different view on these resignations
I've not heard anybody make this comment
before mostly because I don't watch any
TV shows or listen to any radio show so
maybe people have made this comment and
I've missed it if you didn't resign
after Trump said that there were very
fine people on both sides of a neo-nazi
rally in Charlottesville Virginia over
the summer your morality is questionable
your motivations are questionable and
your integrity integrity is questionable
in other words once Trump said that
there are very fine neo-nazis when there
was a horrible show of violence in
Charlottesville Virginia to hear that
and say I'm going to continue working
for this man that in and of itself is
the red flag for me
yeah Gary Cohen was actually thinking
about resigning after the
Charlottesville comment Oh was it I
didn't pull through with it so I don't
know if that's a good reflection on him
or a bad reflection on him because
they're considered it uh well I guess if
we're kind of ranking these guys
considering resigning is better than not
considering it but actually resigning is
even better than that I don't know and
so I think that he's a half step above
some of these others and that it
occurred to him maybe this isn't
somebody that I want to be working for
and I assume Gary Cohen is Jewish from
his last name
it seems particularly rancid to be
working for a guy who is out there
saying there are really very fine people
amongst a group that certainly is not
Pro Jewish I don't even know what what
the word is that I would use in terms of
building an understanding of the Trump
philosophy to the extent that it exists
this is kind of a sign of a purity test
right and that's a common trait of
authoritarian leaders you only have
people working for you who are
completely and totally loyal to you in
all ways all the time and as soon as
there's a disagreement and here it was
Gary Cohn saying I don't think these
tariffs are a good idea he's out and
meanwhile Trump is insisting that things
are just great at the White House
tweeting recently the new fake news
narrative is that there is chaos
in the White House wrong people will
always come and go and I want strong
dialogue before making a final decision
I still have some people that I want to
change always seeking perfection hint
more resignation soon
there is no chaos capital see chaos only
great energy capital e for energy it's
sort of funny in a sad way that Trump
thinks everybody wants to work with him
and yet almost half of his staff has
left 43 percent turnover rate as I told
you I imagine the analogy I have is the
little kid that nobody wants to play
with sitting in the sandbox building
moats to keep all the other kids out who
of course don't exist none of the kids
are trying to get into that sandbox
that's sort of what Trump is here yeah
and soon there won't be chaos in the
White House at this rate there already
anybody less because that nobody will be
working there yeah it'll be just Trump
and I don't even know who will be not
even there so it maybe not even Trump
himself yeah it'll be an empty Oval
Office it'll be Merle Lago the Mara Lago
is a ssin of the presidency send me your
thoughts who's gonna go next that's
actually what I'd love to hear from you
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show boy do we
have a long-form piece for you coming up
later today today's episode of the
program is made possible in part by
brilliant which is really a fantastic
and unique online service that has sort
of reinvented the way people learn math
and science if you watch the show you're
already probably generally curious about
how the world works and you like to
learn new things maybe you have a sort
of casual interest in physics or solar
energy or AI philosophy computer science
but you're ready to take it to the next
level and whether you already have a
grasp on these subjects or you want to
engage and acquaint yourself with these
topics for the first time brilliant is
the place to go you can actually learn
hands-on by solving problems and puzzles
that were designed by expert educators
and professionals and you can start
right now sign up for free at brilliant
org slash David Pakman the first 200
people who visit brilliant org slash
David Pakman will get 20% off an
annual premium membership that is
brilliant org forward slash David Pakman